mon secours dans le viseur de bruxelles
accusé par l'allemagne d'être à
l'origine de l'empoisonnement supposé de
l'opposant russe alexeï navalni le
parlement européen a adopté hier une
résolution contre la russie il demande
aux états membres une intensification
des sanctions existantes moscou poursuit
son enquête et appelle au respect des
procédures
c'est une histoire mystérieuse
étant donné que dès le 27 août le
parquet général de russie a envoyé une
demande d'actes judiciaires et qu'il n'y
a toujours pas eu de réponse
pendant plus d'une semaine cette demande
s'est trouvée on ne sait où on nous a
expliqué qu'elle était au ministère
allemand des affaires étrangères
mais celui ci ne l'a pas transmis au
ministère de la justice russe on nous a
dit qu'elle avait été transféré au
bureau du procureur de berlin mais qu'il
n'allait rien nous dire sans le
consentement de la famille il a ajouté
allez-y lance une enquête criminelle
nous avons nos propres lois selon
lesquelles nous ne pouvons pas engager
des poursuites pénales sur la seule
parole prononcée par quelqu'un il faut
respecter certaines procédures
une investigation préliminaire a été
lancée après l'incident
elle est toujours en cours ce qui a
permis d'examiner toutes les
circonstances de la faire